Understanding South
Africa's Genocide Case Against Israel
Part Three: The Evidence.
Now that we're up to speed
on the context,
let me show you
what's in this 84 page document
accusing Israel of genocide.
The case starts right away
with their main argument,
that the acts by Israel
are genocidal in character
because they are intended to bring
about the destruction
of the Palestinians.
And then they list
the genocidal acts in question.
They argue that Israeli officials
have been publicly calling for genocide.
There’s an entire section
with statements from the Israeli
president, prime minister, and the military
that South Africa is saying proves this.
This is important
because as we talked about in part two,
the definition
legally of genocide must include
an explicit intent
to destroy Palestinians.
Page 30
kind of gets to the heart of this case.
Killing over 21,000 Palestinians,
including 8000 children. Injuring 55,000.
Displacing 85% of the population,
attacking hospitals
and pushing Palestinians “to the brink of famine.”
There’s obviously much more to
this case than I can cover here,
and I suggest that you
read it on your own.